دمار كبير تعرضت له مدينه اديمانان
ادمايان المشاهد حقيقه مروعه وصلنا الى
المكان قبل ساعه تقريبا وتمكنا من
اجراء جوله سريعه على المدينه الدمار كبير
السلطات المحليه تقول ان قرابه 1900 مبنى
قد تهدم بشكل كامل هذا احد المباني ايضا
في المدينه في الدميان فقط قضى نحو الف
شخص نحبهم تحت الانقاض دعونا اولا من حيث
نحن نتعرف قليلا على ما الذي جرى
لدينا مالك هذا المبنى السيد خالد السلام
عليكم
ابي نردم
قلنا
السيد خالد يقول انه مالك هذا المبنى كان
يعيش فيه مع عائلته الممتده قتل تحت
الانقاض عشرين شخصا منهم تمكن من الخروج
من المبنى قبل انهياره بشكل حكام القرابه
عشره اشخاص تم انتشال شبعه اشخاص على قيد
الحياه ولا يزال البحث جاري عن اربع اخرين
من بينهم والده وشقيقه السيد خالد الدمار
كبير والاخطر فيما يجري في مواقع الحطام
كما ترون هناك ابنيه شبه مدمره لكنها لم
تنهار بشكل كامل وهذا هو الخطر الاكبر
حاليا في هذه المدينه ابنيه كثيره تضررت
ولم تقع ولم تنهار بشكل كامل في الموقع
الذي نحن فيه نستطيع ان نقول ان هناك على
الاقل خمسه مباني متضرره بشده وايده
للسقوط في اي وقت بعد هذه المباني يتكئ
فقط على على الاحجار المقدمه المقدمه هذا
المبنى
كالذي ترونه خلف المبنى المنهار بالكامل
هذا الشارع تعرض لدمار كبير رغم ذلك هناك
العائلات الكثير من العائلات لا تزالوا
بجوار المبنى في انتظار اي خبر عن
المتواجدين تحت الانقاض ادمان تعرضت لدمار
كبير كما قال رئيس اردوغان قبل قليل عقد
مؤتمر صحفيا في مقر جمعيه افاد تبعد عن
هنا قرابه 200 متر قال ان الدمار كبير
وتوجه برساله الى سكان اداميان ان الحكومه
ستقف الى جانبهم
ستدعمهم في محاوله ايجاد مساكن للعائلات
التي باتت بلا ماوى ستحاول ايضا دعمهم في
المساعده على ايجاد الشقق مؤقته يستطيعون
السكن فيها ودفع ايجار هذه المساكن ايضا
تحدث عن ضروره الاسراع بمد المدينه بمزيد
من الامدادات الصحيه والغذائيه ليس فقط في
اد عبد السلام اثناء توجههم توجهنا اليوم
الى هذه المدينه مررنا باكثر من منطقه
وجدنا اشخاص كثيرون المئات من السيارات
تتوقف عند مداخل المدن التي تعرضت للدمار
هناك عائلات لا تزال تستخدم سياراتها
للبقاء خاصه اثناء الليل نتيجه حجم الدمار
وايضا تكرار الهزات الارتداديه التي تلت
وما زالت تتوالى ايضا في اكثر من مدينه
كما تعرف هنا كما ذكرنا 1900 مبنى تهدم
بشكل كامل وهناك المئات من المباني
المتضرره والتي تحتاج الى تدخل سريع من
قبل السلطات وعدد الضحايا وصل الى الف شخص
في ادميان
عبد السلام